bienvenue monsieur ati telemann sur rt
france merci d'être avec nous alors
l'europe va donc mettre en place des
droits de douane sur 4 milliards de
dollars d'exportations américaines
concrètement qu'est ce que cela signifie
dans ce conflit qui oppose airbus à
boeing ou surtout qu'on n'arrive pas à
trouver un accord alors que
objectivement on avait la possibilité de
s'organiser d'une manière qui était un
petit peu plus logique
il faut se souvenir que l'année dernière
il y avait une première décision de l'om
c'est qu'ils étaient en faveur des
américains qui jugent airbus qui avait
estimé qu'elle avait un certain nombre
d' aide qui étaient illégales qui
auraient pas dû être données dans ces
conditions normalement en toute logique
les américains auraient dû attendre de
voir quels étaient les pénalités qu'elle
est reporté sur boeing pour que les
européens puissent taxés dans l'autre
sens sauf que donald trump dans sa
politique un petit peu agressive a
commencé à taxer sans attente de voir
alors arrêté il y avait un équilibre
mais maintenant que les américains ont
commencé à taxer d airbus beaucoup de
l'équipement européen et bien finalement
les européens doivent compenser et
doivent se rattraper d'où l'obligation
de lui mettre en place cette taxe mais
l'objectif
objectivement ce serait beaucoup mieux
si tout le monde s'organise est les
américains n'ont pas taxer la totalité
ce qu'ils avaient le droit si vous avez
renoncé à quelques milliards évidemment
l'europe pourra également renoncer à
quelques milliards de son côté ce serait
vraiment le souhaite tout le monde
aujourd'hui et peut-être que le
changement d'administration sera
l'occasion évidemment de revenir sur les
baisses sur les tensions qu'on connaît
actuellement
d'ailleurs pourquoi cette décision entre
en vigueur aujourd'hui alors que
l'élection américaine vient de se jouer
il n'aurait pas fallu attendre
la mise en place d'un nouveau président
la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
américains taxent les produits européens
donc on perd déjà des marchés on perd
déjà de l'exportation airbus n'arrive
pas à vendre ses avions mais en plus ils
sont taxés aux états unis dans les
proportions très importantes
donc on sait aussi que boeing va pouvoir
recommencer à livrer son boeing 737 max
dans les prochaines semaines peut-être
d'ici la fin de l'année en tout cas et
du coup bas là aussi c'est pour mettre
la pression sur boeing et donc
indirectement sur le gouvernement
américain au moment où l'avionneur va
pouvoir un petit peu sortir la tête de
l'eau avec son 737 max qui cloue au sol
depuis mars 2010neuf donc très
clairement on le fait maintenant parce
que si on attend début janvier
eh bien peut-être que golino radja peu
et qui peut exporter des dizaines et des
dizaines d'avions vers l'europe à ce
moment là alors on parle d'une guerre
entre boeing et airbus est ce que c'est
une guerre d'égal à égal
alors ya des injustices des deux côtés
il ya clairement des choses qui ont été
faites mais parfois on est aussi sur
l'aménagement d'un rond point qui a été
payé par l'état oui finalement ça rentre
en compte
il ya quand même des injustices
objectivement parce qu'on a les états
unis par exemple qui soutiennent
beaucoup plus largement leur industrie
nationale en faisant des recherches qui
est quasiment gratuite
il y avait dans les accords aux
américains de 1992 on oublie tout ce qui
s'est passé par le passé toute la
recherche militaire qui a profité à
boeing dans le civil on oublie les
usines qui ont été construites pour
faire des avions militaires
ces cadeaux et en fait on est reparti
sur des bases qui était censé être saine
ensuite à la fin des années 90 il ya un
avion que les américains ont commencé à
développer qui s'appelle solide cruiser
qui devait voler presque à la vitesse du
son que personne n'a acheté c'était un
échec commercial
par contre le boeing a pu faire de la
recherche gratuitement et comme ils ont
annulé ce projet ça a pas été pris en
compte dans les aides et dans les
équivalents qu'avec le côté aux états
unis et en europe
et du coup ils ont eu de l'aide gratuite
et ses petites choses là sont finalement
même si l'om c'est ne l'a pas pris en
compte
on sait que les américains ont quand
même été relativement plus avantagés que
les européens dans cette dans cette
guerre commerciale
d'ailleurs l'europe qui va être
autorisés à imposer un des taxes à
hauteur de 4 milliards de dollars c'est
moins que ce qu'avait obtenu une
américaine et une dernière puisqu'il
s'agissait là de 7,5 milliards de
dollars de taxes comment cela se fait-il
c'est en plusieurs temps en réalité il y
avait déjà quelques
milliards de dollars qui avait été de
pénalité qui avait été autorisé pour que
l'europe table sur les américains mais
sa date de la fin des années 2000 et les
européens avaient vie ben nous on va
attendre de voir si c'est équilibré
donc en réalité si on additionne ce qui
n'a pas été mis en oeuvre les quatre
premiers milliards et les 4 milliards
qu'on a encore un droit de maintenant il
ya huit milliards de route due pour les
européens il ya 7 milliards pour boeing
encore une fois les européens pourraient
plus taxés simplement maintenant comme
on l'a pas mis en place il ya une
dizaine d'années les américains le
disent c'est plus valides sauf qu aura
été c'est quand même de l'argent qui
date d'un certain temps certes on a
attendu mais y'a rien qui dit que ces
quais et date de péremption
donc la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui si
tout le monde taxe est il y aurait 8
milliards contre les américains y aurait
7 milliards contre les européens
balle au centre si on était judicieux on
arrêterait tout on s'organise ray sans
oublier évidemment qu'une large partie
des exportations européennes profitent à
pauline et inversement il y avait
beaucoup d'équipementiers l'européen qui
fournissent des pièces des moteurs des
systèmes internes aux avions et donc
quand on empêche boeing d'exporter sa
touche aussi parfois des emplois
européens
c'est pour ça qu'on a vraiment intérêt à
s'organiser à s'entendre et il ya un
grand espoir
on la remet la taxe pour montrer qu on
ira jusqu'au bout cette fois ci on veut
pas se laisser avoir
mais par contre il est très probable que
début janvier on puisse retrouver un
équilibre et toutes les taxes douanières
saute c'est un conflit qui dure depuis
une quinzaine d'années maintenant
pourquoi
ça n'arrive pas à prendre fin parce
qu'il ya tout le temps des suites il ya
des appels et puis il ya des éléments
supplémentaires et puis on revient sur
un accord puis il ya un avion qui est
annulé et puis finalement l'avion on
arrête de conseil deux a380 mais voilà
maintenant payer des pénalités pour
avoir construit l'a380 et pour l'avoir
aidée de telle ou telle manière
il ya des recalcul de choses qui ont été
faites dans le passé il ya des prêts
qu'ils étaient trop avantageux et donc
elle certains pays qui doivent récupérer
de l'argent chez airbus
mais les fins on a vraiment été chercher
la petite bête
objectivement quand on parle
d'aménagement routier
bah oui ça profite effectivement au fait
qu'on puisse faire passer des autres
tronçons d'avion sur des ronds points
mais aussi d'autres personnes qui en ont
profité quand on allonge en aéroport
quand on allonge une piste effectivement
ça profite pour faire des tests à
bollywood à airbus
mais d'un autre côté il ya peut-être
aussi l'aéroport qui va en profiter pour
accueillir des avions plus gros et tout
ça sa durée d éternité il ya vraiment
des calculs au centimètre près c'était
excessivement complexes et à chaque fois
qu'elle ma décision était prise il y
avait un appel et ensuite les américains
qui avaient aussi ralenti l'om sait on
se souvient de l'intrus n'a pas désigné
les nouveaux juges pour aller au bout de
la procédure
le coc vidal également repoussé tout ça
donc c'est pour ça que ça à projets sur
des années
moi c'était déjà mon sujet de fin
d'études en 2012 est déjà à l'époque on
estimait que c'était un sujet qui est
excessivement loin et complexes sont qu
à l'époque en tout cas personne
n'imaginait que ça durerait encore huit
ans merci monsieur tutelle mme anna va
rester avec nous le rappelle vous êtes à
consultants en aéronautique mercier